[Music]
let's start off with the problem a
person drops a pound of bricks and a
pound of feathers down from their window
which has more matter the bricks or the
feathers
now you might be tempted to say feathers
but let's recall what matter is
matter is anything that occupies space
and has mass mass defines the quantity
of matter in an object
Mass tells us when we have a lot of
matter like an elephant or only a little
bit of matter like a mouse
so back to the problem
which has more matter a pound of bricks
or a pound of feathers
well they both have a mass of one pound
so they have the same amount of matter
now even though bricks and feathers are
very different they're both made up of
matter
but what exactly is matter made up of
matter is made up of one or many
microscopic building blocks called atoms
an atom is the smallest unit of matter
and they are so tiny that a penny
contains approximately 2.3 times 10 to
the 22nd atoms or 23 sextillion atoms
however all of the sextillions of atoms
in a penny aren't the same
a penny is made up of copper and zinc
atoms copper and zinc are just two
examples of the 118 different elements
that exist
an element is a substance that cannot be
decomposed into a simpler substance by
chemical means
essentially if you have an element no
reaction with heat or another chemical
can break it down into a simpler
substance
hydrogen oxygen carbon gold and arsenic
are all different elements
when you have a sample of an element it
can consist of one or more atoms
so Elemental neon exists as a singular
free atom which does not interact with
any other atoms
Elemental gold usually exists as
millions or trillions of connected atoms
while oxygen exists in a diatomic
molecular form with two oxygen atoms
oxygen in its Elemental form is an
example of a molecule because its two
atoms are chemically bound together
a molecule is the smallest physical unit
of an element or compound and it is
anything made up of two or more atoms
held together by a chemical bond
so if atoms are held together by bonds
then it also makes sense that these
bonds can be broken and allow different
atoms to then bond together
almost like Lego blocks
for example water or h2o comprises two
hydrogen atoms and one oxygen atom
in this chemical reaction hydrogen or H2
and oxygen or O2 react to form water
the chemical bonds holding the diatomic
oxygen molecules together are broken so
that each oxygen atom can then bond with
two hydrogen atoms by rearranging the
way that atoms are attached to one
another reactions like this can occur
where one molecule is transformed into
another
a good analogy is that atoms are like
letters and molecules are like words if
we change the order or type of letter we
make different words with different
meanings
if we change the order or type of atom
we make different molecules with
different properties
so let's summarize what we have learned
matter is made up of atoms and we can
obtain different types of matter from
objects being built with different
elements
so while a pound of bricks and a pound
of feathers have the same amount of
matter they're made of different
Elemental building blocks called atoms
that then give them different properties
this is why a pound of bricks dropping
down from above is a lot scarier than a
pound of feathers
[Music]